[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
star trek
what is this
star trek look i'll admit i've seen
maybe i've seen the next generation i've
seen deep space nine i've seen
this right a little bit surprised
never really like i'm not i wouldn't
consider myself like a hardcore star
trek fan but i definitely have scraped
more than the surface of it and know
enough about it this is not star trek at
all there's nothing about it so the
dance there was no dance party it feels
like every team coming of age netflix
like trans movie
remember when picard was was uh had a
dance party to stop the borg
number one please get the solo cups
the neon one we're partying that's right
the homosexuals from discovery are
coming
make it sir
dwarf is super angry
worf is just grinding his teeth
this is a disgrace
data get the glow sticks
we're partying
i think it's good oh [ __ ]
hey does your replicator have like calm
too
why don't you get it straight from the
tap
captain i put in for a transfer
where are you going wolf i'm i'm gonna
go back to the klingons
i can't stand those people but i mean at
this point you've left me no choice
captain all of a sudden everyone just
starts turning on the on the federation
it's just like
everyone keeps defecting to the
cardassians
and everybody just keeps leaving
what's going on
people are voluntarily becoming borg i'm
sorry captain but they have a superior
culture
and they don't allow themselves to be
subverted
you know all of this started happening
the moment the ferengi's took over the
federation
the frankies are just going around going
you know you're all just being very
uptight
let's all have gay sex oh
you know the fdl the ferengi defamation
league is not very happy right now of
course not that a lot of people don't
know is that the ferengi definite
information league was founded back in
the day uh when a famous ferengi
raped and murdered a little girl and
then tried to blame it on the klingon
i'm pretty sure it was the black janitor
with the stuff on his forehead
look at this face does this look like
the face of a pedophile and a murderer
[ __ ]
captain they keep calling me a silver
fox what does that mean riker's like the
guy who's low-key [ __ ] red pill but
he has to shut up or it's gonna [ __ ] his
rank up he's like sure captain it's
great
it's great
number one i hear you've been posting
anonymously on message boards
[ __ ]
ah i i see you've been posting under the
name space [ __ ] crusher 1488.
dana dana gets kicked out of [ __ ]
starfleet because he was going no
captain x chromosomes and white
chromosomes are actually different
making one person a male another one a
female he gets immediately kicked out
i'm sorry captain but these new gay
arrivals are actually way more likely to
uh spread stds and less children ah
that's not good data that's hard saying
that start shooting out stats you know
13 of the people on the ship captain all
right all right data please stop
i'm sorry but captain i feel like maybe
perhaps we are culturally incompatible
with these people that's racist data
deanna troy has a [ __ ] headache every
single day because everyone's confused
on the ship i can't i can't be here
anymore
captain do you know every time somebody
gets their dick cut off i feel it i feel
it it's terrible it's the worst
captain it appears as if all of the
trans people keep killing themselves
it's quite the anomaly
we're not allowed to talk about that
data
q shows up and he just looks around he
goes
nah
[Laughter]
and meanwhile everything
every time he's every time data says
something they should they show [ __ ]
captain picard going don't say that data
it's racist but rikers behind him
mm-hmm that's right he's right
captain it seems half of our all of our
white male uh officers have just stolen
escape pods and left
jordy keeps taking off his visor on
purpose and have to see any of the [ __ ]
going on on the ship
oh my god 44 of the crew keeps hitting
on young wesley
i don't know i keep going to the
holodeck to work out and they just keep
showing up
they keep looking at me what is it dr
crusher uh my son has been molested 47
times on this ship
i'd like to go home my husband keeps
repeatedly being raped by homosexual
pedophiles on the ship i want to go home
star trek the current generation
the replicators only being asked to make
poppers and molly
you know those machines are usually used
for food
for what
i don't know what that is
cocaine food
you know you know let me tell you
captains of real silver fox
there's nothing we can really absorb
from these people except uh stds
i assimilated them and now i have aids
captain uh i calculate a great
percentage that if we allow the board to
assimilate only the trans people
that half of the people on the cube will
kill themselves make it so
they just they just send all the trans
people over to the queue
and they send them right back
you're playing pong with them they just
go back and forth
[Music]
we've killed 45 of the borg
we're all gonna get commendations for
this oh [ __ ]